revista de prensa en directo américa de
francia 24 y me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez más de un rosa bienvenida
buena mañana del lunes hoy vamos a abrir
revista de prensa con un repaso de las
portadas que hoy destacan de que se
cumple un año desde que los talibanes se
tomaron el poder en afganistán con la
toma de la capital kabul
exactamente raúl y como comprenderán los
medios internacionales van llenos de
este primer aniversario de la retoma del
poder por parte de los talibanes del
poder de afganistán vamos a ver algunas
de las portadas que hemos querido
destacar empezando por público de
portugal que titula afganistán un año
después de la caída con una foto de alí
cara para writers the independent de
reino unido señala protestas una un año
después de la toma de los talibanes
vemos en la imagen mujeres
manifestándose y también referencia a la
crisis del país y es que está
estrechamente ligada esta represión de
los derechos de estos recortes sea de
derechos con la crisis que vive el país
sobre todo por este aislamiento
internacional que es precisamente lo que
destaca
de colombia que titula la soledad en
afganistán con esta imagen también que
vemos aquí detrás way to day señala la
caída de afganistán un año después el
caos y la incertidumbre se han
convertido en la forma de vida y destaca
la imagen de la que titula caótica
salida de estados unidos y de la
coalición occidental del país no dice
eeuu prometió seguridad sus aliados y un
año después continúan sufriendo para
escapar imágenes que sin duda vimos hace
un año rosa que le dieron la vuelta al
mundo y quedaron por supuesto para el
historia por impactante que eran sobre
todo las personas cuando iban en el
avión dejando tratando dejar afganistán
continuamos entonces con el repaso de
los acontecimientos que han marcado un
año de gobierno talibán por al yazira
oms exactamente que empieza este repaso
con pues la toma de kabul el 15 de
agosto de 2021 cuando strauss kahn y el
presidente hasta ese entonces salió huyó
del país y se refugió en abu dhabi y
reconoció oficialmente que los talibanes
habían tomado el poder del país también
me han destaca esta línea temporal sin
duda la caótica salida de eeuu y de toda
la coalición occidental destaca la
reimplantación del ministerio de la
promoción de la virtud y de la
prevención del vicio y las consiguientes
represiones de los derechos de las
mujeres y de otros derechos humanos y lo
que queríamos destacar sobre todo es
cómo termina esta línea temporal y es
que al yazira decide ponerle punto y
final hasta el momento con la fecha del
pasado 2 de agosto de 2022 cuando la cia
lanzó un operativo en el que mató al
líder de al qaeda ayman al zawahiri que
recordemos estaba escondido en una
residencia en las afueras de kabul la
capital afgana precisamente vamos a
ampliar y detenernos en esta información
rosa porque el editor de new lines
marquesinas and nathan aborda esta
relación que eeuu tenía de matar alierta
alcalde a al zawahiri el primer año del
triunfo de los talibanes porque se
relaciona esto bien empecemos dando un
poco de contexto
artículo y ya de hecho a este ataque de
la cia este ataque con drone que acabó
con el líder de al-qaeda ayman al
zawahiri quien tomó digamos el liderazgo
de la organización tras la muerte de bin
laden bien empecemos por el preámbulo de
este artículo dice haber matado al
zawahiri es una victoria simbólica para
by the no porque sobre todo se le
atribuye al zawahiri un rol central en
la planificación de los atentados del 11
de septiembre de 2001 por otro lado dice
haberlo matado también demuestra que
eeuu mantiene el pulso a la guerra
contra el terror incluso un año después
de haberse retirado del terreno de
haberse retirado de afganistán sin
embargo dice que a pesar de que la
muerte de alce bajini sean buenas
noticias él al zawahiri ya no era
relevante para nadie desde hacía años
por un lado dice estaba desconectado de
las bases militantes que lo veían como
un anciano que vivía sus últimos años
refugiado escondido en afganistán por
otro lado dice su grupo de viejos
seguidores se vacío por un lado
sospechaban de sus vínculos con irán o
se frustraban ante su incapacidad de
liderar y es que se le atribuía se le
atribuía una gran falta de carisma
comparado con a bin laden dice perdió el
control de las franquicias locales de
siria e irak a los que amenazaba
ferozmente no dice a lo largo de los
años sus pomposas declaraciones públicas
se convirtieron en una especie de
comedia mórbida incluso dentro de los
círculos extremistas sin embargo dice en
los patrones de un grupo debilitado
estaban claros pero se derramaron un
sinfín de líneas de tinta por parte de
expertos y de medios de comunicación
sobre las amenazas que lanzaba al
zawahiri pues a los grupos sobre los que
había perdido el control sobre todo las
franquicias como decíamos de siria e
irak ya la posibilidad de un
resurgimiento de la organización en
siria e irak precisamente antes de
atacar nuevamente a occidente pero como
decíamos las algas han el editor de new
line defiende que estos patrones
de la organización estaban claras pero
que los analistas internacionales
decidieron prestar más atención a
personajes simbólicos como al zawahiri
en lugar de a las tendencias dentro del
movimiento no armado digamos fascista de
corte yihadista dentro del que se
inscribe al qaeda y también pues los
talibanes así es rosa y aquí donde
asegura que la llegada de los talibanes
a colas un año cerró un ciclo no
exactamente porque lo que defiende es
que como decíamos no prestar excesiva
atención a estas personalidades como era
al zawahiri impidió impidió como dices
ver las tendencias no la realidad del
movimiento sobre el terreno dice la
llegada de los talibanes a kabul hace un
año cerró un círculo un círculo que
precisamente comenzó en afganistán entre
otros lugares con movimientos locales
dedicados a luchar contra las fuerzas
invasoras o contra enemigos a locales
esto a finales del siglo pasado esta
tendencia asegura fue descarrilado por
internacionalistas como osama bin laden
y más tarde como al zawahiri que querían
una guerra global contra occidente pero
esta tendencia asegura volvió a
encarrilarse en los últimos años cuando
estos movimientos sean militantes
comenzaron a enfocarse de nuevo en la
lucha local y aquí destaca la toma del
control de afganistán por parte de los
talibanes no fue un momento catalizador
que hizo que los insurgentes sunitas se
dieran cuenta de que los combates
locales podían ser más rentables que las
guerras que libraron los bin laden istas
y que sólo trajeron destrucción y
miseria a las comunidades sunitas en
todo el medio oriente la victoria de los
talibanes sólo reivindicó una tendencia
ya creciente dentro del mundo del
yihadismo dice incluso el estado
islámico se ha tenido que entrar en lo
local no y dice precisamente la ausencia
de estas tendencias en el enfoque
analítico es lo que genera que el
contraterrorismo
sea como sea una industria de rocha dora
dice al final es una cuestión de
pragmatismo bin laden pudo ser alabado
por los fundamentalistas en todo el
mundo pero incluso los más desquiciados
conocen que su legado tuvo costes
considerables asegura para concluir los
que se centraron en combatir a occidente
como al qaeda y el estado islámico
perdieron mientras que los que se
centraron en dominar la escena local
prosperaron y termina diciendo que hay
que ver como las luchas locales acaban
definiendo estos movimientos en los
próximos años rosa como siempre gracias
por toda la información en esta revista
de prensa que vamos a seguir analizando
este tema con este primer invitado el
día